and my uh area of interest is like uh
sequencing and Analysis of genetic
material okay all right so how did you
get U interested in the research part of
it do you plan on going for your
PhD uh yeah in future uh yes of course
I'm going to plan for it so that's why
I'm preparing from now
itself okay all right thank you so much
M so let me check yes um we have few
more minutes uh before we start the
webinar so we'll go over to the next
participant uh anik hello
anik uh anat can you hear us I guess
uh he is not available all right so then
let's move on to the next question
s yes Dr Guan it's uh nice to see you
back yes thank you so much Dr Guan for
confirming uh perhaps we can move on to
the next participant uh s could you
please also introduce yourself and let
us know what are your uh research and TR
let us know your education
background
I guess there seems to be some network
error at the end but if you don't feel
shy or anything please feel free to uh
introduce yourself just be relaxed it's
going to be an Interactive session
throughout right from the start till the
beginning till the ending if you have
any questions you can uh let us know and
uh we'll be able to guide you on that so
all right let's move on to the next
person if you're not able to unmute
yourself you can uh introduce yourself
in the chat box as well and uh I can
read out and then so that we can get
from here so the next person um toell
are you with
us could you please also introduce
yourself what is your education
background what is your research
interest I can see that u a lot of the
participants are from the bioinformatics
background do we have any participants
from biology background or computer
science
background okay sure Dr Guan okay no
problem okay thank you so much dran so
Dr Guan says he is from a biology
background and what are your research
interests can you please let us know
that as
well okay his interest is in onology
and uh we have couple more participants
who have joined so who would like to go
next uh okay can answer NGS so thank
you and U
abilash how are
you can you also introduce yourself you
can let us know about your education
background and research interest in the
chat box all of the participants feel
free free to uh introduce yourself and
if you have any queries you can um
unmute yourself and ask or you can put
them in the chat box and will be able to
guide you all right so um we are late by
two minutes I'll just quickly start with
the
um okay Ry can you try connecting your
audio I can see that the audio is not
connected let
meala can you please type in the chat
and let her know that uh she has to
connect her audio because that is why
she's not able to hear all right so
without further delay I'll just quickly
start with the session but please uh
continue to introduce yourself in the
chat box and let's keep it interactive
all right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is shrii
and I would like to welcome you all for
the webinar on omix logic multi om
research program so this program is a
comprehensive research uh program that
covers various aspects of omix data
analysis and research and it's designed
to accommodate a wide range of
participants from high life schol
students to experience research and the
program offers a Hands-On approach to B
informatics guiding you from basic data
analysis to Advanced research
methodologies with even opportunities
for publication and now in this webinar
we will be covering several topics such
as key features and Associated resources
of the research program introduction to
our Cloud research infrastructure help
you choose the right specialization
track that best aligns with your career
goals an interactive life q& session as
well as the various scholarship
opportunities that are available to the
participant and uh before we begin with
today's webinar let me also take a brief
moment to introduce you to the team
behind the program since I can see that
couple of participants are new to us and
uh are hearing about the program for the
very first time so we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and Commercial
collabor ators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make B informatics more
accessible and now we have had the
opportunity to work with coordinators
from different parts of the world to
offer btic training programs reaching 24
K plus participants in different
countries across different
specializations including oncology infe
diseases Precision medicine neuroscience
and data science and as the part of the
program you will have access to the omix
logic resources which includes training
modules data analysis tools durated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with the mentors to give the
student a clear path of the Bloom's
taxonomy Pam and now this also comes
with an access to our course fors which
include courses on B informatics
Precision medicine multiomics including
genomics transomics metagenomics and
epigenomics data science that includes
btics using R and Python Programming as
well as CH informatic and example
projects of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work now the omic platform also
gives options for analyzing a given data
for instance you can learn B informatics
without any coding at all and for those
interested in opting the non code
pathway they will be given directions to
access the T binfo platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data and this platform includes demo
pipeline as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
PIP so now to view the various courses
example projects and student projects
we'll first start by signing up on the
omix project learn portal and I'll walk
you through a brief demo on how you can
get
started so here is the link for for
signing
up okay so here for those of you who are
new to this uh program and you're
hearing about it for the very first time
then uh this is the learn platform where
the participants once they enroll in the
program they'll be able to access
various training resources that they get
access to so to be able to guide you on
how you can uh get started you need to
first sign up on to be able to do that
if you don't have an account uh
previously on the portal you can visit
the link that I've shared in the chat
box and click on the create an account
option that you see
here and once you click on this you will
be asked to enter your name email ID and
password as well as several few details
such as your University uh and so so you
can enter those details and click on
submit and your profile will be great or
if you already have an existing social
uh accounts such as Google Facebook
Apple GitHub or Twitter you can simply
directly click on those and create an
account linked with your existing social
media handle so with that I'll just
pause for a couple of seconds for the
participants to sign up so that I can
help you walk walk you through the
different uh components on the portal
where the mentor will be guiding you as
a part of the research program in just a
while so let me know in the chat once
you have signed up please put a yeah and
if you already have a existing account
on the portal and you are good to go put
a done in the
chat and uh I have opened my chat box
and on the side so I'll just uh pause
for two to three minutes so that you can
find
okay sh has already signed up risi has
signed
up if you're facing any technical issues
while you're trying to login or creating
an account you can uh let us know in the
chat box and our technical team will be
able to uh help resolve the issue so
that you can
have
well done aash she has also signed
up thank you
Nika all right kavia has also signed
up Sak has also to sign
up all right lakmi has also signed up so
I'll just uh proceed ahead with
navigating and show uh showing you how
you can get started uh so please feel
free to continue to let me know in the
chat once you have signed up and if you
have any issues once again uh you can
let us know so I'm going to sign in
using my existing uh social media uh
existing email ID and
password so here once you sign up uh you
will be able to see the very first page
that you are seeing is the courses page
right so before we uh navigate to that
the first thing that you have to do once
you sign up is to complete your profile
so to be able to do that on the top blue
bar you will see welcome back with your
email ID there click on that and it will
take you to your account setting right
and here you will see a profile button
click on that and here the first thing
that you have to do is complete your
profile right incl uh make sure that
your name is improper capitalization and
there is no spelling error because as
you complete the courses and you get the
certificate this name will be printed on
it and also add a brief buy about
yourself as your educational background
and research interest and link to your
social media profile and add a uh
profile picture or uh your University's
logo and your profile should be showing
100% complete right and now you
if you head to the courses tab that you
see here you'll be able to see the
various courses that we uh provide on
the portal uh which ranges topics from
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
as well as case studies on various uh
specialization topics such as oncology
infectious diseases and so so here in
the search bar if you enter a keyword
that you are interested to learn about
let's say you are interested to learn
genomics then you can simply enter that
and it will display the relevant forces
and example profits and now another tab
that I want to show show you is the
programs tab there you will find the
research program um that is part of
today's webinar right and along with
that you'll also see several other
training programs in uh different fields
that you can explore at uh your own phas
so uh that is all that I wanted to talk
about in uh getting started on the omix
logic learn portal and navigating on the
portal and now to introduce you to the
training program the various features
the SOS resources and various
specialization tracks i' would like to
pass on the stage to my colleague
sonalika who is also mentors of the
program over to
you thank you so much Shari for the
overview and a very warm welcome to all
of you uh good morning good evening or
afternoon in whichever part of the world
you are I'm sonalika R and I'm the
bioinformatics project manager at Pine
biotech and today we are going to talk
about the structure of our research
fellowship program we have designed this
program to cater to Learners from all
the backgrounds and we have organized it
into three distinct levels to ensure a
gradual and in an indepth Learning
Journey so the question that arises is
is why you should join the omix logic
community and the training and the
research program now what is the need so
to answer this question in the ever
evolving field of omix research there's
continual advancements in technology and
software that has improved processing
capabilities but the data sets under
study are often vast and they require
substantial Computing part and memory as
well beyond what most personal computers
can handle and accessing and working
with publicly a uh available data can be
complex typically requiring coding
skills which many biologists lack
likewise the analysis pipelines and the
programs that are involved often demand
coding expertise and in University
settings the students receive valuable
theoretical knowledge in research
project design but they lack the
knowledge knowlege and research project
design or a hands-on experience due to
these technical
limitations and the faculty members
often specialist in their own research
areas May struggle to cover diverse
topics or unfamiliar Technologies
outside their expertise for instance a
professor well vered enene expression we
have limited knowledge of metagenomics
in
seawat so to address these several
issues that are are present in terms of
what is there in the Academia and uh how
you can work on the research process
without being an expert with the coding
we'll try to understand today how we can
join the program and learn from this
program how we can use the automated
pipelines to process or automate our
research work and get our results to
interpret insights spend less time on uh
working with the code block for analysis
but more time on the
interpretation so the omix logic
research program is designed to provide
an exceptional opportunity for
researchers and students to delve into
the world of bioinformatics and harness
its potential for analyzing complex life
science data and through a well
structured blend of online resources and
personalized guidance from expert
mentors the students would engage in
diverse omix research projects now who
can join the program so omix logic is an
all encompassing platform designed to
meet the needs of a wide range of
knowledge Seekers it is inclusive and
welcomes everyone including high school
students or graduates researchers even
individuals from non- bioinformatics
backgrounds so whether you are just
starting your educational Journey have a
degree in hand or you are pursuing
stutting age research omx logic would
offer resources courses and tools that
would cater to a unique level of
expertise and interest and it's a space
where individuals with diverse
backgrounds and goals can come together
to explore and engage with the exciting
world of bioinformatics and omix data
analysis the research fellowship program
is designed with three Progressive
levels that cater to individ uals of all
the backgrounds so there are three
levels beginner intermediate and
advanced the beginner level spans around
two months it provides foundational
knowledge with predefined research
questions and project reports the
intermediate level would last for three
months and it will let you propose your
own research question and work on a
desertation finally the advanced level
spans around 6 months that equips you
with Advanced Data science tools and
techniques to address your research
question aiming for research publication
and this inclusive program would welcome
high school students graduates
researchers and those without a
bioinformatics background ensuring that
anyone can embark on a rewarding
research Journey I'll take you through
each one of these levels in more depth
and we try to understand what are these
different levels all
about before I get on to discussing
about these different levels I wanted to
discuss about the different resource
specialization tracks that you can work
on in the research fellowship program so
there are several tracks that you can
work on one of them is oncology oncology
research focuses on cancer related
studies and therapies then you have
Precision medicine that emphasizes
personalized Health Care based on
individual genetics and character istics
then you have infectious diseases that
explode diseases caused by pathogens
such as bacteria viruses and fungi then
are metabolic disorders that Encompass
research on conditions like diabetes and
obesity then you have Neuroscience that
investigates the brain and the nervous
system to understand the cognition and
disorders and then there are Fields like
system biology agriculture space onics
and cem informatics system biology
studies complex biological systems and
their interactions agriculture research
centers on improving crop yield and
sustainability and space omix examines
omix data and space environments for
space exploration a very interesting
field that's coming up and then you have
chem informatics that focuses on
computational methods for chemical
research we have met a lot of research
fellows and some of them come with with
an idea what they want to work on a
topic or a field that they want to work
on with and different types of data that
they want to explore but we also meet a
lot of newbies who are not sure or not
clear which specific path do they want
to select that's why we wanted to
discuss about the different tracks that
you can pick your research question from
and get started now the now there are
different types of research
specialization tracks that I just
discussed and what type of study is
possible under uh the track but I also
wanted to discuss what type of data for
all of these different tracks can you
explore so in your research journey
within the various specialization tracks
that I just discussed you can harness
the power of diverse omx data types
there are Fields
called uh the generalized word is omics
that is collection of something you have
phenomics genomics epigenetics
transcriptomics there are also Fields
like single cell transcriptomics
metagenomics so genomics allows you to
Del into the genetic makeup of organisms
uncovering DNA variations that are
crucial for precision medicine
Agriculture and space exploration then
you have transcriptomics that provide
insights into the gene expression
patterns shedding light on the molecular
mechanisms behind the diseases cellular
diversity and responses to stimuli
single cell transcriptomics will take a
more granular approach examining
individual cell behavior that is vital
for understanding complex systems such
as the nervous system or tumor micro
environments and then you have
epigenomics that explores modifications
to DNA that impacts gene activity aiding
research in areas like metabolic
disorders and Neuroscience lastly
metagenomics that is invaluable for
invest instigating the microbial
communities whether in the human gut
soil ecosystem or infectious diseases
offering insides into the interplay
between hosts and their
microbiota now these omix data types
provide powerful tools to explore the
intricacies of your chosen
specialization and uncovered novel
insights now many of you might be
thinking um that you don't have a
background in omx's field if you are
from I heard uh the participants telling
that they from biochemistry or
biotechnology or microbiology but not
the code
bioinformatics those who are from the
code bioinformatics field they might
have uh dealt with such type of omix
data but for the wet lab students you
need not worry we'll take you through a
training process we'll teach you uh a
specific type of omix analysis that
you're interested to work on with and
then take you a step ahead with your
research I'll discuss what the process
looks like in my next slides so that was
about the research specialization tracks
that you can work on uh obviously one
track that you need to pick based on
your research interest but those were
the possibilities from where you can
pick your specific research interest and
the different types of data that you can
work with all these different types of
uh data could be used for each and every
specialization track that I previously
mentioned in the previous
slide so I mentioned that we have three
different uh levels the beginner level
the intermediate level and the advanced
level now these levels definitely vary
in terms of duration in terms of uh the
project the research project question in
terms of the outcomes of the program but
also with the program you have a
specific curriculum that we have put
together to teach you while you are
working on your research project because
as you learn only then you can Implement
those things or those Concepts uh for
your research work so the first level is
the beginner level I'll take you through
very briefly about these different
levels it's very important for you to
understand what each level cerss so that
you can pick the level that works for
you at the moment so the beginner level
has three uh has uh six specific
sessions that you need to cover in the
initial phase uh of your research work
the moment you join the program and then
you start working on your uh research
question the first session in the first
session we will discuss about how to
identify the research gaps and formulate
research questions you'll learn how to
to conduct a literature review to build
a strong foundation for your research in
the second session that is the research
proposal and research methodology we'll
dive into the process of creating a
research proposal that outlines your
Project's objectives significance and
methodology understanding the different
research methodologies and how to choose
the most suitable one for your study
will be the key Focus here and then you
have the Third third session that is
data analysis and the project timeline
so this session will cover the basics of
data analysis techniques we'll also
discuss how to create a project timeline
ensuring you stay organized and meet
your research Milestones the fourth
session would be around budget and
resources ethical considerations and
project management this session is very
important for those who are working on a
research work in an institution it could
be PhD Scholars or researchers I won't
say this session would be important for
those uh who are in their graduation or
postgraduation but yes go through the
session so that you know what steps to
uh consider in future so in this session
we'll discuss about budgeting resource
allocation and the importance of
financial planning for your research
ethical considerations in research are
critical and we'll explore the ethical
guidelines as well that you need to
follow you'll also learn about effective
project management to keep your research
on track this is one of the very
important things that I feel every
student uh be it a graduate postgraduate
or a researcher should have a skill of
project management because I've seen a
lot of students working on their project
and missing out on their deadlines and
not me not meeting their Milestones on
time and that really messes up with your
project because the last St you just
rush and put together everything uh not
making complete sense of your results
also I've seen that because you don't
have these project management skills you
work a lot but you're not able to put
together a good meaningful presentation
to showcase the work you really did um
for months so this is what we'll discuss
next the next session is on data
collection and validation and data
interpretation so this session will
focus on collecting and validating data
for your research and we'll discuss
methods for data interpretation and how
to draw meaningful conclusions from your
findings we'll discuss somewhat about
the visualizations we'll also cover
about visualization in detail in the
sessions though but this would be an
overview and finally project
presentation project presentation is a
skill to put together everything that
you worked on for months in months to
put together it uh to put it up together
as a story
in those slides and present what you
worked on what methodology you opted
what results you obtained and then how
do you conclude your presentation is
very important so we'll discuss how to
uh compile your project that effectively
communicates your findings and we'll
also cover the process of submitting
your research project on the portal so
that is what the bner level uh research
fellows will learn
now those who join the intermediate and
the advanced levels will definitely uh
learn about these several first six
sessions that I've mentioned and also as
I mentioned those who specifically join
the beginner level program only they
would be working on a predefined
research question because it's just for
two months now why did we put this
option of a beginner level curriculum or
a beginner level for the research
fellowship program we have received a
lot of queries from different
universities where students are supposed
to work on a mini project or they want
to have a research project or they want
to get an experience with a specific
type of comic analysis during their
internship and they have to submit their
certificate for internship or mini
project or submit a mini project to
their college uh for their Academia so
there are there could be a number of
reasons and there are also High
schoolers who want to work on a research
project present it in an exhibition or a
science fair and that helps them get uh
away or submit their application or
complete their application to get to
their dream college so there could be a
number of reasons because time is a
limit here you just have two months that
you can work on that's why we have put
together some predefined research
questions for you so we have these
research questions that we are already
working on and also we have uh the pre
analysis of the of these different
components already done and you would be
responsible to carry out a literature
review and work on the analysis and
interpretation a customized analysis
that we tell you that you have to work
on so you get the halfway done and half
work done and then you have to work on
the analysis and the interpretation now
I'll tell you about some of the
predefined research questions that we
are proposing today for different
research specialization tracks you can
pick any one of these predefined
research questions if you're interested
to get a taste of the different research
tracks or different types of omx
analysis for your um experience or
Project work the first one is oncology
it is one of the exciting areas of
research to understand how the specific
genetic mutations can lead to resistance
to cancer drugs and here we are looking
for ways to develop a targeted therapy
to overcome the resistance another focus
is to identify the unique molecular
signatures and the biomarkers that are
associated with the progression of
breast cancer which can lead to more
personalized treatment approaches for
patients now these are two topics for
oncology I have just specified two such
questions for each of the tracks but if
you wish to work on a different uh
specific track we can have a call and we
can let you know about the other topics
that we are working on as well the next
is a Precision medicine so Precision
medicine is all about tailoring
treatments to individual patients and we
are researching how to identify the
genetic and the molecular markers that
can predict how a person would respond
to specific medication and this can lead
to highly personalized treatment plans
additionally we are investigating the
genetic factors that affect drug
metabolism helping us optimize the drug
prescriptions next is infectious
diseases so here we are exploring the
genetic diversity and the evolution of
the influenza virus in different regions
and this knowledge can help us design uh
either better vaccines or antiviral
drugs a better therapeutic approach in
short and we would also like to study
the transmission dynamics of diseases
like uh malaria aiming to reduce their
spread in endemic
regions so that was about these three
different tracks and what topics are we
focusing on the next one is neuroscience
so in Neuroscience we are focused on
understanding the underlying molecular
and cellular mechanisms of neurod
degenerative diseases like Alzheimer's
or Parkinson's and our goal is to
develop Innovative therapies to slow or
H disease progressions and we are also
exploring how genetics and epigenetics
influence brain development and the risk
of mental health disorders like
schizophrenia aiming to identify early
biomarkers for early
intervention another field is
agriculture where we want to look at
ways to optimize crop breeding using
genomic data and also we are studying
the the genetic factors and metabolic
pathways that make the plant resistant
to pests or diseases and diseases with
the aim of promoting sustainable and
eco-friendly farming
practices next is metabolic re uh
disorders metabolic disorders research
centers on understanding the molecular
factors that contribute us to condition
like insulin resistance in type two
diabetes so we are working on targeted
therapies to improve insulin sensitivity
and additionally we also want to
investigate the metabolic underpinnings
of obesity and its related Health
complications such as fatty liver
disease and our goal is to develop
personalized interventions for weight
management last but not the least is
space
omic why space omic so in the fascin
rearm of space omic we are researching
how Extended space missions affect the
human microbiome and this knowledge can
help us develop strategies to mitigate
health risks associated with microbiome
changes during space travel we are also
exploring the genomic and the proteomic
changes in organisms export to extreme
conditions in space and this information
can um this specific information would
inform the development of biot
technological solutions for space
exploration as well as
colonization these were some fields that
I wanted to discuss some topics that we
are working on and have plans to work on
and also uh there are other fields that
uh I have not discussed in Greater
detail but if you're interested let us
know you can email us we can uh have an
exploratory call with you and discuss
and those things would be around CH
informatics that we can uh discuss
specifically around chem informatics
so those were some of the topics under
the beginner level that I wanted to
discuss next comes the intermediate
level curriculum again to mention the
ones who take up intermediate or
advanced level would definitely have the
access to the beginner level sessions
that I discussed but the one who takes
up the intermediate level has to propose
his or her own research proposal has to
propose his or her own research question
so if you already have a uh question in
your head but you want to discuss with
us three minut a little bit and then you
have a proposal ready you submit it to
us and um then we start working on it so
you perform the literature review you
look for the data set you explore the
data set and you process all and you um
go ahead with all the pre-processing
steps and the analysis you'll have all
our support we'll be assisting you at
every step but it's just that the
research question is yours the
intermediate level is for three months
you get more time to work on your
research project and because you will
get more time to work on your research
project that's why you have some more
sessions to refer to to get that
learning to learn about specific types
of omix analysis now these training
sessions would basically help you build
your Concepts so these training sessions
are actually a series of lectures and
also some coursework that you have to
complete that will assist you to
complete your research project as I
mentioned the outcome of the beginner
level could be a research project a mini
project but the outcome of an
intermediate level could be a
desertation project so a lot of
Bachelors and master students uh have
this criteria to have a desertation
project submitted to their college or
university to get their final degree so
the intermediate level would cater to
that me where you can work on your
desertation project obviously because
you get more time so you can uh work on
this specific or you can work in this
specific
Direction now let's discuss what the
training of uh the intermediate level
would look like so as I mentioned that
you have to pick your own research
question that's why it's very important
for you to understand the different
resource specialization tracks today I I
just introduced you to the tracks I did
not discuss much in depth about each one
of these so in the seventh session we
will discuss about each research
specialization track in detail and based
on your interest you can pick the one
that you want to work on we will explore
the unique challenges and the
opportunities within each specialization
that will allow you to align your
research uh to focus with your passion
and the eighth session would be around
omx databases and data retrial so let's
say you have a resarch specialization
track that you want to work on for
example you want to work on oncology
next thing is to uh first of all pick up
a specific type of interest of uh omix
data that you want to work with let's
say uh amongst all those different omix
data types genomics transcriptomics
metag genomics and single cell or
epigenomics I say I want to work with
transcriptomic data so the track is
oncology I want to work with
transcriptomic data related to oncology
it could be any type of cancer um let's
say I pick liver cancer the next thing
would be to extract the data to look for
data I want to look for liver cancer
data sets so it's very important for you
to learn what are the different oric
databases from where you can retrieve
the data so in this session we would
introduce you to various omx databases
and the importance of data retrieval now
data retrieval is not very easy
different databases have uh data
uploaded um in different formats and in
different ways so how do you retrieve
the data how do you uh clean the data
those are some of the things that we
will be
discussing so here you will learn how to
navigate and extract the relevant data
from the databases to support your
research now there are different uh omix
tracks that you that you could pick
genomics metagenomics or transcriptomics
now here you have a choice it's not that
you take all the sessions I said that
I'm interested in transcriptomics so if
my interest is transcriptomics I just
take 11th and 12th session if your
interest is metagenomic you just take
metagenomic session why we have put
these sessions here so that we can guide
you in more depth how to work with a
specific type of omix analysis if it is
genomic data analysis that is your
interest so we'll teach you or we'll
delve into the genomic data analysis
that will focus on variant calling to
identify genetic variations and you'll
also learn how to perform functional
annotation to understand the
implications of genetic changes and the
philogenetic analysis to trace
evolutionary relationships so we'll
discuss these different uh possible
analysis
that comes under genomic data analysis
or that is possible with genomic data
okay next is metag genomic data analysis
now metagenomic data analysis is
essential for understanding the complex
microbial communities as I mentioned and
because you now want to analyze or
understand the composition or the
abundance of these different microbial
communities it's important for you to
learn about different tools and
techniques that you could use uh to
analyze microbial data now these tools
could be like data 2 or k those are the
two specific pipelines that we would be
focusing on that will help you uh
understand how to process and analyze
data allowing you to explore microbial
diversity taxonomic classification Alpha
Beta diversity um etc etc the list goes
on and in the next sessions session 11
and and 12 you will learn about
transcriptomic data analysis so RN is a
powerful tool for gene expression
analysis and many of you might have a
good Hands-On with this type of analysis
as well but if not then these sessions
will help you learn how to ex um how to
explore the data so once you have the
data with you you need to perform
exploratory analysis to understand the
data set in your hand we'll discuss
various statistical methods for
differential gene expression analysis in
this session the next session is on
differential gene expression analysis
where we'll dive deeper into the
analysis of differential gene expression
that's a very critical component of omix
research you'll learn how to identify
the genes that are significantly
upregulated or down regulated in
different conditions which is crucial
for understanding biological
processes so the intermediate level
sessions will build on the foundation
that you establish in the beginner level
that allows you to specialize in a
specific research track and also gain
in-depth knowledge in omix data analysis
that is valuable for your research
Fellowship so that was all about the
intermediate
level the next level is the advanced
level so for those who are aiming to
publish their work the advanced level is
where it all comes together so in the
intermediate level you could just get to
the need of submitting a desertation to
your um college or university or maybe
work on a research project if you're a
PhD scholar but if you have a
requirement to publish a paper it's very
obvious that it's not possible in a span
of three months to learn work on a
project and then also publish your work
uh that's why the advanced level was uh
developed or put together that will help
you advanced level is for six months
first of all and this specific level
will help you with the specific set of
tools and techniques that you require to
perform uh a good research work and also
have the opportunity and the time
definitely to uh prepare a manuscript
that could be further
published now while I mentioned the
advanced level will give you the access
to these sessions uh that would help you
in advanced research and I say so we
learn we learned about different omix
analysis in the intermediate level it's
very important for you to also learn
about the tools and the techniques that
could be used uh to perform analysis
with that specific type of data or
perform Advanced analysis I'll say uh in
the intermediate level you learned about
genomics metagenomics transcriptomics
you need to pick one track of your
interest advanced level will help you
learn about uh single cell data analysis
or single cell transcriptomic data
analysis the first three sessions of the
advanced level are around omix analysis
and then are tools and the techniques
the 13th session is about pathway and
functional enrichment analysis where we
delve into advanced RN analysis where
you want to learn about the pathways or
the function enrichment of the
differentially expressed gen you want to
understand which Pathways your
differentially expressed genes effect
and um also you want to understand the
enr along with the enrich Pathways the
functions of uh the function of your dgs
providing valuable insights into the
underlying
biology the next two sessions are on
single cell data analysis it is one of
those techniques or analysis that a lot
of researchers are working on but
because the sequencing of this type of
uh data is quite poisly uh is uh quite
costly that's why it's not a routine or
you'll not find a lot of single cell
data available but there are a lot of
databases from where you can extract
single cell data and you also have uh an
amazing Pipeline on single cell data
analysis so uh for this for this
specific track we have put two sessions
so here we will explore the databases
first of all how to retrieve the data
what are the different types of
techniques to get the access or retrieve
the data and work with the specialized
data and we'll understand where and how
to obtain the single cell data that is
crucial for advanced research and
building on the previous session we'll
then dive into the analysis of single
cell data focusing on cell type
identification differential expression
trajectory analysis some Advanced out of
analysis
and also learn about or understand about
cellular heterogenity and Dynamics so
that was about the omix analysis
different types of omix analysis now if
you're not interested in single cell but
if you want want to do genomic data
analysis you just refer to the genomic
session and not the Single Cell one
that's an option given to you but we
definitely will recommend that you take
up these sessions so that you learn
about the different types of omic
analysis and maybe in future you can uh
work with any other type of
analysis and then from the 16th session
onwards we are talking about the um most
talked about topics data science so data
science we'll here introduce you to the
data science principles and the
techniques that are specific to omix
data you'll explore data pre-processing
feature engineering model selection and
for more Advanced Data analysis you can
refer to it we'll also uh teach you
about machine learning different types
of machine learning unsupervised
analysis supervised analysis what are
these different tools that could be used
for both of these different types of
analysis and how do you work with them
we'll teach you through the automated
pipelines and also through
script so that was about unsupervised
and supervised analysis of machine
learning and we have three sessions on
supervised analysis taking each
algorithm at a time and then following
the process where you have the data and
then you prepare your data and then you
separate it into training and test set
and then you apply different algorithms
check the accuracy evaluate your model
and then you deploy it I've just given
you a very brief overview so we'll
discuss the entire flow and also we'll
discuss about each and every tool why is
it used how is it useful when to use it
uh etc
etc okay now in the next sessions we
will discuss about uh um are in Python
not everyone is um a a techy here not
everyone wants to get into the coding
but those who are interested to learn R
and python for biomedical data analysis
I think the advanced level is best for
them because uh learning R and python
will um I say make you a full package of
where you know about the different types
of analysis and also you know about
different libraries that could be used
for this analysis so it will um help you
build a good research project but also
gain a good experience uh
alongside so in the next session we
introduce you to the languages first of
all it's not important that you have to
learn R and python both alongside you
can pick one language at a time either r
or python we'll give you the resources
to learn any of the languages r or
python for biomedical analysis if you
want to learn both of them perfect
so here we'll discuss about RN python we
introduce you to the languages how to
process data how to perform expiratory
analysis how to perform statistical
analysis also in the session name we
have not mentioned but in the coursework
you'll learn about machine learning as
well how to apply or build different
machine learning models using R and
python now we get one question a lot of
times how many hours you need to
dedicate for each level see the number
of us it it's really it really depends
on you now there are some people if you
have a non- bioinformatics background
you might have to give more number of
USS if you are a working professional
and you have time on weekends you can
give more time on weekends and you can
accommodate your timings on the week
days and if you are a student and you
have more time uh on the week week days
as well then you can accommodate
accordingly there are some students who
are fast Learners so you you might
require less time so accordingly we
provide you with the resources it
completely depends on you how much time
you take to go through these resources
but yes we'll do provide you with
deadlines to make sure that you achieve
your mark on time and uh we we'll keep
assisting you with your questions
clarify your doubts and uh take you a
step ahead towards your
research so that was about the different
levels beginner intermediate and Advan
if you have any questions you can put in
the uh chat box and I'll now take you to
the uh omic learn portal where I'll just
show you all these different levels and
what resources what access to the
resources you have any
questions you can also unmute
yourself
all right so if there are no questions I
now proceed ahead so uh this is the
program page that you might have seen on
the social media as well so once you're
on the omix logic learn portal you will
find this page under the program St this
program page is very important for the
program because you'll find all the ass
ated
resources uh that I just went through
the sessions the recordings the lectures
the cours work everything on the program
page how can we get the data if you're
interested in particular topic that's
what we'll teach you how to get or
extract the data from databases or
repositories for a specific topic that
you're
interested uh Dohan is asking how how we
will do our analysis as we know that
bioinformatics need large computer
resource which Maybe v machine can't run
though the answer is T bioinfo platform
I just take you to the T bioinfo
platform where you have these pipelines
you just need to extract the data uh
through links you can refer to the
specific data set that you want to work
with upload your data here or uh put the
links to that specific data set from the
from the data repository and everything
will run on server you'll be given 5tb
space where
everything uh would be done from
pipeline processing you get the results
you just have to download the results
and interpret them okay uh I'll take you
through the platform just give me uh
five minutes five more minutes I'll just
take you to the platform it's not an
online machine it's an it's a server
basically it's an online server and your
are allocated space on the server and
you can uh run the educational pipelines
to learn first of all how the analysis
is performed and then you perform it
with your own data so that is how it
would
work okay now um I'll tell you how to
get to the program page I'll just show
you the different components of the
program page and then I'll take you to
the resources that you get an access to
with the program when I say resources I
am referring to the coursework and this
platform TB info platform to um process
the pipelines so there are two things
don't get confused onx logic learn
portal that is like your uh training
guide you have all the resources here to
learn from then you have the TB INF for
platform to perform the Practical
handson so you go to the programs and
here on the second page you can also put
in the search bar research and you'll
get this program
page now on this program page if you
scroll down you have the specifications
of the program then you have these three
different levels beginner intermediate
or Advanced you have to pick up one of
the levels based on your research
interest and I'll just take you shortly
how do you register on the program page
itself you'll find these different
levels you pick the specific level that
you want to enroll with and then you the
moment you do so you'll unlock that
specific level for yourself
so here you have these different
sessions these are the sessions that I
took you through uh when I was going
through the
presentation and here you'll find the
link to the lecture you'll find the link
to the resources which will include
coursework uh the courses that you have
to go through supplementary material
additional material link to literature
or research articles or additional
material that you can go through all
right and you just have to watch it
complete the material and work on a
research project we will be meeting
every week where we will discuss your
progress we'll take up your queries
we'll um take up your queries and
rectify them and help you proceed ahead
with the next step now what are the
resources that come along I mentioned
cours work so you would pick one type of
omic analysis let's say uh you want to
work with transcriptomic data you pick
one type of omix analysis learn how that
specific type of omix analysis is
performed and then when you have to
select a research question or an area
that you want to work on uh then you
pick up a research specialization track
if you want to analyze RN data for an
Alzheimer's condition or for a specific
type of cancer or for um metabolic
disorders diabetes or obesity that way
so now let's say you want to learn about
transcriptomics uh before I hit on the
transcriptomics coursework let's jump to
the initial step let's say you are a
newb and you don't have an idea what
specific type of pic do you want to
refer to for uh you as a newb we'll take
you through the first course that is
Introduction to
bioinformatics now this specific course
will intr you to the different fields of
omic genomics transcriptomics metag
genomics it will help you understand
what this field is all about what this
field includes what type of data has to
be analyzed in this field and different
applications so this this is a
coursework these are different lessons
you open up a lesson inside the lesson
you have context you have images uh to
supplement your understanding you have
videos to watch you have quiz quizzes
and assignments to answer to check your
knowledge so that is uh how a lesson is
built okay now you go through the this
cour work and then you let us know which
specific faiure interested to work with
now the next step is let's say you
specify that transcriptomics is that
area that you want to work with sorry
for the typo okay you mentioned that you
want to work with transcript onics so
the next step would be
and Advanced Training you go through the
transcriptomics course work now in this
course workor we start from the very
Basics uh even if you don't have a
background with transcriptomics it's
perfectly fine we start with the very
Basics we'll start with the concepts of
uh what is
transcriptomics how transcriptomic data
is sequenced what are the different
sequencing techniques what are the
different sequencing types and then once
once you have this data how do you clean
the data what are the steps involved to
clean the data pre-process the data uh
and then perform expirat your Downstream
analysis what is the flow and also what
are the different tools that that you
have to use okay so inside these lessons
you have the concepts explained and you
also have the Practical Hands-On
explained so you have the steps that you
need to perform so uh
if I am not wrong Dohan yes Dohan asked
how to perform the Practical Hands-On
okay uh we definitely know that a system
will support it not everyone has a high
Computing system actually no one has it
with them and their
places sorry so uh in the coursework you
have these
lessons where you have the steps
specified you you have a detailed
description on what the what tools are
to be used what those tools do and uh
what are the different steps what are
the different parameters and then how to
com um complete the processing of the
pipeline and then what results you get
and how to interpret them so that is one
thing now everything from the very
beginning understanding how the data is
preprocessed to expiratory analysis or U
Downstream anal Anis the next thing is
you learn how to perform statistical
analysis or tests differential
expression analysis regression analysis
machine learning everything around
transcriptomic data right once you have
completed the uh coursework and once you
have a good Hands-On the specific type
of data analysis the next step is just
to get an overview of how the concepts
that you learned could be applied to
answer a research question before you
really start working with your your
research question so you went through
the coursework first of all you
identified your area after that you
picked up a specific coursework learn
the analysis and this coursework would
also be supplemented with Mentor
lectures you watch the lectures for each
step understand the flow and then you
also go through some case studies these
case studies are not very lengthy
they're very short case studies but it
will help you build a concept so after
you know the concept accept how to use
it to apply uh to a research question
that is what you will learn okay so that
was about the cours work that you uh
have to complete uh as a part of the
program that's actually not not a lot of
cours work uh it's basically it's
definitely a gradual learning process
you learn a thing and then you apply it
so that's the way it should work I
mentioned about the tbio info server so
let's have a look at it the the this is
the Practical Hands-On platform that you
would have to uh use now
definely there are three things that we
would refer to we'll refer to open
databases to exam data we also refer uh
we'll also refer to the uh open uh or
publicly available tools and techniques
that you can use or publicly available
softwares that you can use for analysis
and we'll also explore the T bioinfo
platform so we'll explore all the
different aspects of informatics tools
softwares and techniques uh in R and
python as well that you can use to
analyze your
data so when it comes to the T bioinfo
platform there are different areas of
analysis on the platform transcriptomics
genomics single cell metag genomics uh
virology uh then you have the ftic
analysis here for machine learning you
have pipelines there are several
pipelines uh I'll just take few minutes
of yours I know we are uh at the time of
ending the webinar but I just take a few
minutes to give you a quick Hands-On
with what these pipelines are and uh
show you how to process them and how to
interpret the data so here you have
these dropdowns these drop downs have
some case studies or pre-built pipelines
we call them demo pipelines why they are
called demo pipelines here the data is
already uploaded at the back end and you
just need to process the pipeline look
at the result and understand what these
results are and learn to interpret the
result it's not difficult on a platform
to uh take the data and process the
pipeline but it's important for you to
understand how to interpret the result
so how do you upload your data the this
is a usual pipeline you simply upload
your file it could be your txt file it
has to be your txt file or an svl link
or HTP link or FTP link so Dohan you
were asking uh how do we do that we can
also refer to to these different links
that we can get from the databases okay
and then we upload our data and then we
process the pipeline I quick quickly
take you through one of these pipeline
processing so this is a pipeline I can
simply start the pipeline use some
specific uh
algorithms uh what these algorithms are
why am I using them what parameters do I
need to put everything we'll teach you
in the program
right now I just wanted to show you how
easy it is to uh process a pipeline and
then you have your results that you can
interpret you get the results here you
can click on them it'll download these
are zi finds you unzip them and then you
explore them and you get a dashboard
where you can um change the parameters
and see how your results change with
change in parameters and then these are
the interactive plots that you get
through the pipeline that you can
interact with and interpret your
results so that was a very quick and a
brief demonstration of the T bioinfo
platform there are various pipelines
that we could use for different types of
analysis we'll be talking more about
them once you join the program and with
that I'll pass on the stage to Shri Cori
to quickly show us the outcomes of the
program and uh then we'll discuss the
registration process and then we'll be
good to end the session if there are any
questions please feel free to put in the
chat thank you so much s I'll just
quickly share my
screen so uh the participants have any
queries please feel free to put it in
the chat and along the way we'll be able
to uh answer your question so uh
sunalika gave a very comprehensive
introduction to the various speci
ization F that are there as a part of
the uh research fellowship program and
now we'll take a look at some of the
ways that uh the students have leveraged
these training program and the resources
to come up with various uh out so in
this case uh as you can see uh the
research program was integrated as a
part of the University curriculum which
was part of the systems medicine
graduate program at Georgetown
University
and the training program ended with
students completing a diverse range of
research projects on machine learning
using python to address various research
questions in biomedical research such as
infectious diseases metabolic disorders
Neuroscience oncology and so further
students have also went on to
participate in poster presentation
competitions that we conduct annually
which is the omix Symposium wherein
International experts will attend review
your research project and provide
feedback on how you can improve it
further and there are also students who
have went on to publish their research
project in Open Access journals uh such
as who is a biomedical sence uh student
who is interested in Immunology research
specialization and let's say if you're
someone who is interested in uh cancer
diagnosis treatment then you can also to
offer the onology specialization TR like
canade or did who went on to publish her
research project that's part of a
University at columia and there are also
uh students coming from the high school
background for example morea who
presented his Neuroscience project at
the regenon international science and
engineering fair for which he won the
BAM and presently he is improved in an
undergraduate program at Harvard
University and the we also have uh
students who complete their uh research
project to participate in international
conferences like prianka Sharma and P
they were from biotechnology background
and these projects can also be showcased
as a part of your University application
like some of our students did such as
jaraa Anisha they all went on to
Showcase their research project in
their resume as part of their uh
University applications now taking the
example of Dela itself if you're someone
who is interested in astrobiology and
space omic we had a lot of students from
that background who are still actively
uh passionate about the theme and you
can find a lot of their uh session
discussions as part of the student club
that we have on the YouTube channel now
moving on if you're someone who is
interested in infectious
diseases uh that is also possible and
here is an interesting example where in
the faculties and researchers uh
collaborated through our research
program to publish their research book
and this particular example is part of
the nutti Memorial Institute for medical
research part of university of Ghana and
let's say you're someone with a passion
for Science and business then it is also
possible to pursue an entrepreneurship
and business Innovation track like a
team of industrial researchers from
biologic Support Services which a
biotechnology company in Nigeria de so
they specialized in the uh microbiome
metagenomics and they develop a
microbiome test kit to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and the
interesting aspect is that such
entrepreneurship TRS are not just
pursued by researchers but by students
as well here is an example of a group of
undergraduate and postgraduate students
from India who develop an early
detection kit for Al
and now to regularly stay updated about
our ongoing research project
opportunities student Publications
exciting job opportunities latest re
research articles and there um in
biomatics and data science we encourage
you to follow our LinkedIn group on
machine learning and data science where
you will get frequent updates uh as well
as
studenta so that is all that I wanted to
discuss about the outcome that are there
as part of the research program and I'll
share the link to these groups in the
chat box so that the participant can uh
join the group get started so uh now I'd
like to back from the state
back we'll walk you through the
registration process and how one can so
over to
you thank you Shari okay so now how do
you register for the program so to
register for the program program you
need to go to the program page go to the
programs Tab and there was a question is
it easy to access the omic portal yes it
is very easy but if you have any sorts
of um technical problems navigating the
program you can anytime reach out to us
and we can have a call with you
oneon-one where we can tell you how to
uh navigate the program the portal all
right so once you're on the program page
you scroll down and you have these three
sections bner intermediate and the
advanced level and uh based on whichever
level that you are interested to enroll
in you can pick the pick that level
based on the country that you are
present let's say I'm from India so if I
uh select INR I'll get these three
different levels we are offering
scholarships at the moment and uh we had
a lot of queries in the chat box as well
for the scholarships yes we are offering
scholarships you can reach out to us on
Communications atate find. bio and uh
just put
your uh educational background or if you
are working somewhere you put your
research position name of the
institution or the university and then
you put the scholarship uh reason right
so there's a form that you have to fill
for the scholarship so you email shrii
she can put her email address in the
chat and you just fill out that form
we'll review your application and then
we'll review and then we'll give you a
discount code you take that discount
code click on the buy now button for
whichever level that you want to enroll
in and then you put that specific coupon
code over here and then you click on the
apply button and once you do that the
amount would be uh deduced so that is
how you uh get the scholarship and use
that cin code to put him right so if
you're seeking for a scholarship please
feel free to reach out to us Shari
please put your email address in the
chat box so that uh we can help you get
a scholarship and start with the program
these scholarships are available for um
students from lwi income countries and
also from students from from specific
institutions in universities that's why
I asked you to mention your in tion or
university as well now just to discuss
about the uh specificities for each of
these different levels that I discussed
I'll repeat once again for the beginner
level you get an access for two months
intermediate gives you an access for
three months Advanced gives you an
access for six months in the beginner
level you will be working on a
predefined research question we'll give
you some research questions you either
you can pick from it or the research uh
projects that are ongoing in the company
you you can become a part of that
project and have a customized research
question that you can work on
specifically for your research project
report okay the outcome of the pner
level would be a research project report
that you can submit to your college or
have an experience with and also high
schoolers can enroll in the beginner
level they can take the other levels as
well but if you wish to work on a mini
project for an exhibition or a fair then
you can pick the beginner level and then
comes the intermediate level that is for
three months here you have to propose
your own research question we'll assist
you work on the research question if you
don't have a research question and uh
then you can also um work on this
specific research question for three
months and the outcome of the
intermediate level would be a
desertation maybe that you can submit it
could also be a poster we can help you
with creating the poster for of your
specific research book that you can
present maybe in conferences um or we
can also assist you for these posters in
uh poster competitions in your campus
University or college and then the
advanced level is specifically for those
who want to get an advanced Hands-On
with the tools and techniques of data
science that would be used to apply to
their research question and they want to
have research publication out of their
um research work so they can pick the
advanced level that is for six months so
based on your requirements you can pick
the level that you want again for
scholarships you should email Shri gari
on Communications at theate pine. bio
and we'll R your application and give
you a coup
code all right are any
question just a clarification here that
so most of the participants I believe
have already submitted their
applications through the form so we'll
review that uh existing um submissions
that you have and for those who are new
and joining us for the first time and
have not submitted please uh register
through the form I'll share it once
again and the chair and so after
reviewing the submissions and the
selected candidates will be email with
the scholarship code that will be
provided just
that
if if anyone has any further queries um
let us
know and feel free to connect with us on
LinkedIn uh we have the groups by omix
Logic uh we keep on updating there about
the scholarships available about the
ongoing research work work so if you go
on LinkedIn you have the pages here omx
logic one is this page and then you also
have and then we also have a group that
you can join just like omx logic and
feel free to connect with us on
LinkedIn uh Shar you were mentioning
something please over to
you uh yes we have one query from
miracle that he is a graduate of
biochemistry and he is not cently
enrolled in any institution but he needs
the research experience for his
application Pro so can I qualify for the
scholarship
regard yes yes definitely uh you'll
qualify for the scholarship uh please
mention or please share your resume with
us you can uh we just want to look your
educational background look at your
educational background and also look at
the previous research projects that you
have worked on that would help us
I shared the email ID in the chat box so
if you have any queries you can drop an
email there and our team will get
back perfect thank you so much sh uh do
we have any other questions what percent
of discount there are different uh
scholarships that we are offering based
on the background the student background
so once you send your application to us
we let you know what scholarship do you
get you can uh share it directly uh with
shrii on communication aomix logic.com
yes
all right thank you everyone for joining
today's session and uh we'll see you in
the program once you join the program
we'll have an orientation session to get
you started and we'll keep on meeting
every week to look at your progress and
help you with the next steps see you all
in the program
bye-bye